[Applause]
[Applause]
protesters causing chaos after barging
into a los angeles city council meeting
and threatening lawmakers they were
angry over a measure that would ban
homeless encampments near schools and
day cares police ended up arresting two
of the activists the opponents say the
bill would further isolate the homeless
community and ultimately the city
council though passed the measure judge
i want to come to you on this first we
all agree that you know violence has no
place in any of this that you need to
disrupt um peacefully but what do you
think of the measure itself because this
is something that i'm sure is going to
be popping up in cities all across the
country that are dealing with homeless
problems well you know if they if they
ban homeless encampments near schools
and near daycare centers i mean i don't
think there's anything wrong with that
obviously i think we've got to protect
children in school we've got to protect
children day care centers the problem
with these homeless encampments a lot of
these people are drug users they've got
mental health conditions they've got all
kinds of problems where our kids are in
danger these people who are objecting to
the displacement as they call it the
displacement of the homeless and saying
that that's unfair and illegal are
totally wrong they don't have a right to
pitch a tent in a public place
and i think tennessee has actually
passed a law that says if you pitch a
test a tent on public land it's a felony
for which you get six years in prison
they're not looking to put them in
prison for six years they're looking to
take them to the next level which is to
get the mental health treatment that
they need
what about that dana and what about the
role that affordable housing could play
in dealing with this well that has just
this has been there's like
it's very frustrating the number one
issue in los angeles is a homeless
problem right okay so that is happening
and it's going to be the number one
issue in many cities you can see it
happening in this one here it affects
everybody's quality of life and it
affects your compassion because you
don't like to see people leave it on the
street like that and i don't understand
this
they're happy with no gun zones
but what about no homeless zones around
a school like i think that that should
be something well and the city council
agreed they passed it
the other thing that's happening in los
angeles it's going to be on the ballot
in november
they want to make hotels right report by
2 p.m
what rooms are still available
and you have to do this this would be
mandated and then they will put homeless
people in those hotel rooms for that
night
and you would have no say about it if
you're the hotel owner
and that is something that they want
people to vote on now the people should
vote on it i hope people do come out and
vote on it because the government has an
obligation to try to help the people the
taxpayers are willing to help the people
but these solutions are not going to cut
it
greg what about
that program so everyone including like
the beverly hills hotel also has to
register that's crazy there's a lot of
unspeakable truths that you can't say
about this but you should say yeah right
there are mentally ill people that need
help we have talked about that for years
so i'm not going to get any shame about
being very
this this was only about 10 cities being
banned near schools they should be
banned period period they are not safe
places
these are not like mental mentally ill
people who who need who need help
because these are people that actually
choose to live there and if you say oh
my god nobody has to believe me there
are people that actually believe that
this is the way to live i see them i
walk by them i see the i know i know
them almost by name because i walked by
them on sixth avenue they like places
where they can aggressively panhandle
they need to be in this city to support
their lifestyle right because they do a
lot of it's outdoor recreational drug
use that's what it is you michael
shellenberger has been covering this
forever he ran for governor sadly he
lost but the fact is by conflating this
with the mentally ill which i used to do
but now i see it as a separate thing it
actually hurts the ability to do
something about this in those
encampments people are being sexually
abused there are f there are physical
fights violent fights with actual
weapons it's truly a dystopia and it's
near hollywood who prefers their
dystopians to be like you know the
handmaid's tale these white patriarch
fantasies when in fact just down the
road downtown it is so bad and it's
expanding and expanding it is time to
ban urban camping i agree right because
they're only there because they can be
there
i'll say final fantasy why do liberals
want homeless next to kids i mean that's
weird why were they protesting to put
homeless people half naked shoot up
drugs in front of a nursery school
why would you want that that's
disgusting
we used to have real protest movements
you know they'd protest you know for
civil rights for women's rights protests
against the draft there's nothing left
to protest they're protesting for the
ability of homeless people to smoke
crack in front of a nursery school
that's sick that's insane
if you want to protest fine but
eventually you have to move from the
protest to producing something and if
you're stuck on the homeless okay
they're actually protesting for the
homeless to stay homeless
they're not protesting or producing
anything for the homeless like getting
them off the streets they're like yeah
we want the homeless to stay
sick and homeless and dirty and
disgusting we want that don't try to
stop them from living a depraved
disgusting unhealthy life next to
children
i think some dignified solution that
treats people with respect on both sides
is there any dignity what you get on the
streets there's that's the one thing
that's missing the least dignified thing
to do yeah i'm talking about the
solution that treats these people as
people and also protections i treat them
like people
who's not gonna treating like people is
getting them off the street and getting
them
treatment
how about we treat the kids like people
i do i
have a child why are you pro homeless
jessica
because there are people too the fastest
is up next
hi i'm brian kilmeade i want you to do
me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now